One of the biggest, uh, geopolitical blunders
of this administration has been Donald Trump
sailing on the Iran nuclear deal. Importantly,
without Iran having violated the deal, which
was of course signed under President Barack
Obama. And you might remember as many people
did Trump opposed the deal under Obama. Lots
of right wingers did that and that's fine.
But once the deal signed Willy Nilly canceling
it when you're elected president, absent any
caused to do so based on what's in the deal
is not a good idea. And I've said this before,
if other countries can't trust that the United
States is going to stick to the deals that
we make, even when a president changes, when
the party in the, uh, controlling the White
House changes, there is no incentive to deal
with us. There is no incentive to treat us
correctly. It's geo politically a disaster.
And that's exactly what it has been. I also
told you several weeks ago that Iran completely
predictably is now resuming nuclear research
and development possibly for nuclear energy,
possibly for nuclear weapons, which of course
I don't want them to have.
But the point is they're resuming enrichment
of uranium, which I don't want them to do.
But given the circumstances, it's perfectly
logical. It's perfectly rational. And it's
what we would expect that they would do. Iran
knows that if they are not, uh, if the United
States has bailed on the Iran nuclear deal,
they are better off no matter what happens
in the future. Starting to enrich uranium
again, either they start arranging uranium
so that in the future it becomes a negotiating
point for a future deal. Or they start enriching
uranium either to develop nuclear power or
nuclear weapons. Because if they understand
history, they know that historically having
nuclear weapons has been a strong positioning
item positioning. It has been strong for the
positioning of nations. And there are numerous
examples that we can look at and those include,
uh, we've talked about Iraq, we've talked
about many others, so it's completely predictable
that it's what Iran would do.
I don't want them to do it, but I get why
they're doing it. And what Donald Trump is
now doing is trying to have it both ways.
Trump has bailed on the deal. He has pulled
the United States out of the Iran nuclear
deal, but at the same time is demanding that
Iran stick to the deal unless they want to
face further consequences for not sticking
to the deal. And here's the loophole that
the Trump administration is trying to use
to justify this nonsense. What the U S is
saying is that even though we pulled out of
the deal, there are other countries that are
still in the deal. And this is of course the
height of absurdity, the uh, the Donald Trump
back to the United States out of the Iran
nuclear deal. It was a coalition deal. So
the argument they're making is the u s is
out, but Iran is still in the deal with the
UK and with France and with Germany.
And of course on a technical level that may
be, but then it's up to those countries to
demand that Iran comply. Donald Trump and
the United States have no credibility whatsoever
to even ask for that. At this point in time,
and even worse, is that the United States
has actually made it almost impossible for
the other countries to keep working with Iran
on compliance. So Donald Trump has sort of
put himself into a very strange and idiotic
coroner, but specifically a corner that lacks
all credibility on the issue. And unfortunately,
and this really is a problem, there are news
outlets that are reporting that Iran would
be in violation of the deal if they do this
or if they did that Trump ripped up the agreement.
It makes it hard for other countries to keep
it going. Uh, uh, when Donald Trump does that,
and then yet he still insists that Iran has
to stick with the deal.
And more importantly, maybe we're used to
Trump's hypocrisy and idiocy and ignorance
domestically, but geo politically, this starts
to put Europe once again, potentially at odds
with the United States because ultimately
those other countries, the European signatories
to the Iran deal might have to say, we agree
with the u s even though Trump backed out,
the deal with, uh, us is still on and Iran
needs to abide by it. That would be taking
Trump's side when it comes to this disagreement
or the European signatories might say, even
though this is a multipart deal, by ripping
it up as far as American involvement, the
deal is effectively dead. And we really have
no sort of compliance authority to enforce
that Iran stick to it. And this is yet another
one of these examples of how the United States
will be pitted against Europe. And we've talked
about this before, when the US and Europe
are at odds, this is a win for Putin who wants
to put a wedge between the United States and
our allies.
A lot of petitions, prerogatives and priorities
when it comes to NATO, uh, relate to driving
a wedge between the United States and Europe.
This relates to so much of what we've been
talking about over the last couple of years,
and it's not this cartoonish Trump and Putin
colluding thing. It's that Donald Trump doesn't
even have the wherewithal and the knowledge
and the intelligence, quite frankly, to even
understand the ways in which his actions and
statements regarding Europe and other allies
and his looking away when it's convenient
to look away from authoritarian leaders doing
absolutely terrible things. It all fits into
a politic that benefits Vladimir Putin in
a world in which Russia and China are increasingly
aligned to the detriment of the United States
as sort of the third leg of the nucleus of
the super powers, the three growing geopolitical
superpowers. And we've talked about this many,
many times before. It doesn't have to be Trump
colluding with Putin to be executing a politic
that benefits Putin in ways that Russia has
been thinking about and talking about at least
for two plus decades, if not longer.
This in the end is going to be what it's about.
We'd be better off if Donald Trump had not
backed out of the deal. Iran would be further
back in their nuclear development. Everyone
would be safer, uh, with an Iran that is still
part of the deal and complying with the Iran
nuclear deal. Instead, we have an Iran that
is newly invigorated in its nuclear development.
There are new discussions of war with Iran
on the table, and it's absolutely absurd and
utterly embarrassing on the national stage,
which has basically been the theme of this
administration. If you disagree, uh, let me
know. I want to hear from you about the Iran
nuclear deal, about Iran's actions in resuming
enrichment of uranium, uh, about the context
in which Putin likes the idea of the United
States at odds with Europe, about what does
or doesn't Iran have to do with regard to
what is remaining the Tatars of the Iran nuclear
deal.
Let me know what you think.